-That's right,
SantaCon is officially back
in New York City.
It was canceled last year,
but this weekend,
thousands of people
dressed like Santa
are expected to take part
in a citywide bar crawl.
So I thought
I'd welcome the tradition back
with a tiny song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
♪♪
♪ Christmas in New York
is for you, and it's for me ♪
♪ And a couple of thousand
drunken Santas ♪
♪ Stumbling down the street ♪
♪ With pillows
stuffed under red shirts ♪
♪ The most I ever saw ♪
♪ Fake white beards
and Christmas cheer ♪
♪ And cases of White Claw ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
♪ But they don't got
no reindeer ♪
♪ No cocoa piping hot ♪
♪ Just snowstorms
of Axe body spray ♪
♪ And dollar jello shots ♪
♪ There's Santas on the subway ♪
♪ There's Santas taking naps ♪
♪ One Santa is break-dancing,
one's barfing in his hat ♪
♪ Some are singing carols ♪
♪ Some say "ho, ho, ho" ♪
♪ But most of them
are running, shouting ♪
"Look out, bro! Po po!"
♪ One drunk Santa,
two drunk Santa ♪
♪ Three drunk Santa, four ♪
♪ I saw Santa kiss Green M&M
at the M&M store ♪
♪ So get your booster,
wear a mask ♪
♪ Be safe this SantaCon ♪
♪ 'Cause beer and milk
and cookies ♪
♪ Don't protect from Omicron ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you, Roots.